now remain the most amazing anchovy dip
with vegetables and bread
first cut slices of baguette and bake in
the oven at a hundred and eighty degrees
C for six minutes or until crisp
meanwhile roughly chopped garlic and
shallots and add to a food processor
along with a tin of good-quality
anchovies
sprinkle in some pitted black olives
flat leaf parsley and drizzle in the
reserved anterior oil and a little olive
oil blitz to a paste and add pepper then
decant into a jar ready to transport
serve with a handful of fresh baby
carrots
peppery radishes and your crisp baguette
toasts anchovy dip a portable and
deliciously palatable alfresco treat
[Music]
now a spicy chili yogurt dressing with a
porn salad first things first
I'd like you to make the dressing fish
sauce smell of fishes so one and a half
tablespoons of fish sauce to chili like
this especially if you have it on the
side note a spoon of sugar
oh that's it good and so four
tablespoons of yogurt some zest in there
why you make me a sinner John John
that's a girl this is for a little
picnic and was a great way of
transporting we squeeze the lime in
there and then we put this that sounds
why my tummy only some ducks only
sometimes thank you for that the first
time you have it's like whole thing it's
fresh salty citrusy but delicious
now cucumber and a salad or get rid of
all the seeds so if you just nice and
gently peel the cucumber widely feel it
can you not eat the skin on that you can
eat the skin but I want this salad to
taste lights and fresh you can use a
knife for this - there Chloe you can't
be well-known most people it takes off
the slicey is nice and thinly so much
better
summer Korea that's why it's called as
the peeler it does look a bit like you
now get your spoon see weapons teaspoon
just takes out all those seeds
so while sits it's in the dish it
doesn't make the salad go all soft cause
that cucumber is nice and crunchy that's
really good there you go so see where
your knuckles are there that's what's
always gonna protect people with that
little finger out this little piggy boom
comes off what did I tell you about that
he's knuckle that's the first place you
cut off all the time there you go the
next addition to our prawn salad is firm
juicy baby gem lettuce half the butts
I'm keeping the butts on for now so when
I slice it it stays together a little
bit there we don't use
okay when you prepare that is for picnic
you never slice it to Finley okay
otherwise it will it's good pulls away
Tommy sauce is ready good dressing is
ready turn it off and the trick is you
dress the bottom of your dish because
I'm gonna put the prawns on here to
protect the lettuce get your cucumber I
put my cucumber on and then finally
lettuce okay now the cell is not gonna
go soft why is that because it's not
that it's not straight onto the dressing
that's right
what happens is I wrap this now and then
we get to our picnic drizzle the sauce
on top you mix it up we've got the
dressing on the bottom and the dressing
on top that's right a little bit of
creme film today the king film trip I
don't know the typical trail yet the top
of the toilet was my age
oh you've been my idea then well okay
salad in the fridge with a dressing
ready to go for a picnic